[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
it's now two days since the murder of
sir david amos the member of parliament
for south end west
in the quiet dormitory town of lyon sea
there's still a sense of shock almost
disbelief in the streets
the mp was killed conducting his weekly
surgery meeting constituents in person
here in westminster there would have
been barriers to shield him police to
intercept possible assailants
but every week in hundreds of towns
cities and villages mps and local
councillors breathe life into our
democracy as they come face to face with
we the people
they do so without protection knowing
full well that the next person they
speak to may be there to do them harm
the question is whether the fatal attack
on david amos following the death of joe
cox and similar attacks in recent years
will leave a lasting wound on our
democracy
this morning we contemplate both the man
and the meaning of this tragic act
with increasing focus on the background
of the attacker and reports that he was
referred to the prevent anti-extremism
strategy i'll talk to home secretary
pretty patel who yesterday visited
leoncy to pay tribute to sir david
as that connection between the people
and their politicians comes under
greater strain i'll speak to former
prime minister gordon brown
and we'll talk to labour's shadow
foreign secretary that's lisa nandy
as we remember to david amos i'll talk
to mps in the region on both sides of
the political divide
conservative andrew rosendale and
labour's wes streeting live from leon c
and we'll hear from david stanley
founder and chief executive of the music
man project a charity of which sadebrid
was
president
but first i can now speak to home
secretary preety patel who has described
fellow essex mp sir david amis as a
loyal friend who is deeply loved by the
local mp
morning home secretary um
you were a friend what will be
your memories as to david
i i have endless memories of david um
but he was
he was absolutely engaging and his
energy in particular his energy
enthusiasm passion commitment but also
kindness his absolute kindness to
colleagues in parliament and
i've i knew david for well over around
30 years so that's a reflection of
obviously how long both of us have been
in grassroots party politics
and he was always there as someone that
almost wanted to mentor help support a
sounding board someone that was very
dear and sincere
and those are the bonds that you know in
political life when you're in a
political party at the grassroots
starting out
you look i look to someone like david in
particular
and he was a neighbor of mine as well as
someone that would help assist mentor
guide act as a sounding board and you
know he he taught me so much about
conservative party grassroots politics
but also being a good humble
constituency mp
which really was the embodiment and
epitome of david as as we've seen
through the attributes that have really
been shared around
and spoken about in his constituency as
well and i saw that yesterday
much has been said about him and his
kindness and and so on across the divide
um
he was never a minister
apparently had no particular ambitions
and devoted his career to basildon and
south end um
do you think that this
dreadful
killing
is going to undermine the
relationship between mps and their
constituencies
well i think it's a great question
really and it's one that i suspect many
of my colleagues are reflecting upon
right now this weekend and i've been in
touch with many many
mps
since since this attack on friday
my own view is no
i've always believed i've been a member
of parliament for just over 10 years
and
we are part of the fabric the dna
of society our democracy freedoms
the chance of people to engage with us
but what i would say trevor is a lot has
changed i've seen that in my time as a
member of parliament i think back to the
appalling murder of joe joe cox
and how that again was a moment of
reflection but also quite an intensive
period for members of parliament
in terms of our own
safety
in our own constituencies and there's
been a lot of work that's taken place
since then um and i know and i i'll say
this without going into too much detail
because i think every mp needs to be
conscientious of what they do in their
constituency and how they go about their
business we've all changed our ways of
working because of changing
um concerns threats in society
we for example you know do much more
booking appointments in advance surgery
appointments so so there are practical
things but i come back to actually your
your fundamental premise this should
never ever break that link between an
elected representative and their
democratic role responsibility and duty
to the people that have elected them um
to be their representative
if you want to keep that link
alive then presumably
you may now need to think about
how we keep our members of parliament
and local councillors and so on
safe have you got
thoughts about what we now need to do
because we can't go on like this can we
no we can't we absolutely can't but i
think i think there are two things here
actually one is obviously no question
the safety and security of elected
representatives and yes mps but trevor
you've just said elected councillors as
well thousands of them every saturday
every weekend actually many evenings in
the week as well we're in westminster in
the week but councillors are out there
every single day
to preserve and protect you know that
very essence of our democracy
we should rightly our elected
representatives need to be able to go go
around with confidence with confidence
that they are safe and secure in the
work that they are doing that's the
first point but alongside that you've
asked the second question or the second
point which is around practical measures
there are practical measures there are
many practical measures and i don't want
to sit here and discuss them all but for
example i've alluded to one already
booking appointments in advance checking
the details of the individuals that you
are seeing check in the locations in
advance that you are going to making
sure you're not on your own i could go
on there are other things linked to
policing and security as well um but
there are things already in place but i
i'm now very much and lindsay hall the
speaker of the house and i
with the police and with others as well
we we need to close any gaps basically
where where we feel that you know there
are concerns okay well let's think about
how what those gaps might be closed i
mean lots of
members of parliament and councillors
try to take those precautions all
already but
you for example because of who you are
and job you do have close protection
is it time to consider
making it possible for our elected
representatives to have that kind of
close protection that we would enjoy
here in westminster well i th all these
all these issues and options are in
consideration right now so let me just
say that there's a lot of work taking
place already
um
there's it's possible that the
government prior to friday
trevor prior to friday and you know just
just this tragic and appalling attack
there there is a there is a program of
work that takes place around the safety
and protection of members of parliament
in their constituency and that's working
with the police that's all police forces
around the country how they interact
with their mps and how they look after
the mp in their constituency through
various protective measures
the speaker has already put in a range
of measures post friday as we have with
policing but within that there are other
options that are being considered such
as when you hold your surgeries could
you have offices or some kind of
protection while you're holding your
surgery now it's not for me to determine
the mechanism for that right now but
there are discussions underway right now
looking at a whole spectrum that's only
one example and there are others as well
that are actively under consideration
right now so the government would not
close the door and providing resources
for elected representatives to have for
example security and there are there are
resources there already in the system
that would cover so much of this trevor
so this isn't not necessarily about new
resources but absolutely we will do
everything i'll say this now we will do
absolutely everything to
for me this is and for the government
it's about safeguarding our democracy
and enabling our elected representatives
to carry on um doing what they do
serving the public we are public
servants at the end of the day we are
here to you know conduct our duties in a
way in which surgeries face-to-face
meetings all those kinds of things in
our constituency as well as the work
that takes place in westminster and
would airport style security metal uh
arches sure and so on would they also be
under consideration well
that would be with the police and the
house authorities there there are lots
of things under consideration already
trevor
all right well let's talk about the
perpetrator obviously you can't talk
about specifics
we don't know very much but you have
ordered a review
of mp's security
we've talked about that
you also have underway a review of the
prevent program we already know this man
was
in some way
in the notice
on the radar of the prevent program but
do you think that there is now a case
this one the london bridge uh something
similar for beefing up the review that's
going on as prevent programme because
clearly
it looks as though people are simply
slipping through the net well i think
first of all trevor you've already
touched on this i i can't speak about
any of the specifics and that's totally
not for me to do and that being proper
in light of that as a live police
investigation
prevent is
going through an independent review
right now
it's timely to do that we have to learn
we obviously constantly have to learn
not just from incidences that have taken
place but how we can strengthen our
programs the government has a duty and a
responsibility when it comes to the work
that we do and de-radicalization the
type of programs that we put forward the
investments that we put in place to
ensure that the system is working and
let's not forget with prevent programs
channel programs it's not just a
policing component it's multi-agency
social services education health etc so
that is why there is a review underway
right now we want to ensure that it's
fit for purpose robust doing the right
thing but importantly learning lessons
always building upon what is working and
addressing any gaps or issues where the
system needs strengthening i think it's
also important to recognize right now
that there are so many different
component parts around prevent and
channel programs and it would be wrong
for us to automatically assert that
people that go through or have a
referral to prevent are automatically
going down the stream of
de-radicalization
many of them could have other factors as
well that is the purpose of this review
i understand and i i don't want to take
you into places where
all you can say to me is i can't talk
about that sure
but
do you have any anxieties that this
thing is not
doing what
it was invented to do which is to
intercept
and to
anticipate the sort of problems that
we're seeing emerging both
uh the you know the examples of joe cox
and david amos are the pinnacles or you
know the worst but we know that there
are other
uh examples of this going on
are you not worried at all that this
program is essentially not doing the job
that it's supposed to do i'm not going
to make assumptions right now about the
prevent program and the work that has
taken place over a number of years
trevor if there is an independent review
taking place at prevent right now but
what i would say is absolutely right
through that review program or that
process that's in place that we
constantly learn and we improve and we
strengthen that is absolutely right to
do that is that is why we have the
independent review taking place but on
top of that we have to recognize that
the entire landscape around
radicalization extremism individual
behaviors lone actors it's not binary
it's a complex landscape
and and literally
we have to go under the bonnet as
actually our intelligence agencies do
our police do other aspects of the state
do as round case by case to look at what
is going on
i get all of that but
other public figures other members of
parliament might be sitting here this
morning and saying
we're reviewing we're considering and so
on next week
we are going to put our cells at risk
when is somebody actually going to do
something
well how long do they have to wait how
many weeks do they have to risk their
lives so first of all prevent is going
through an independent review so that's
one thing in terms of your important
point the immediate point around safety
and security of individuals trevor there
is work there is a lot of work that has
taken place already and there is more
work underway
friday yesterday today and going forward
with policing in constituencies but also
with the parliamentary
authorities around security of mps and
that is absolutely geared up i should
emphasize this that is geared up
around looking at this weekend and
members of parliamentary and their
constituencies next weekend members of
parliament will be doing the same again
out and about and alongside that what
are the protective measures that we can
put in immediately so this isn't a case
of let's wait for two weeks three weeks
four weeks these are immediate changes
and measures that are actively being put
in place and discussed with mps
what are those measures right now so
first of all what difference will we see
well first of all
mps have already been contacted by their
local police forces so that's 600 plus
mps around what are they doing what are
they doing sharing information with the
police so that the police know where
they are check in their actual physical
security practice all the practical
measures basically these are one-on-one
conversations that are taking place and
rightly so absolutely rightly so but
with that making sure and giving members
of parliament the confidence for them to
go around in their constituencies and
having that advice from policing and
security as to how to keep themselves
safe let me ask you about a broader
question
which you yourself in a way uh stand at
the center of the issue of civility in
politics
some people have been saying
actually prior to friday but certainly
in the last two days
that
part of what's happened here
is that politics itself has become
quarter that there's
been a language which hones in on
particular individuals and you yourself
have been
i think the subject of
pretty
um unpleasant
commentary and attacks and so on do you
think that there is a problem
with politics itself in particular the
house of commons in the way that
mps talk to and about each other that
has produced an atmosphere in which this
kind of violence can take place
well i think first of all
this isn't just about the house of
commerce this is about wider public
discourse and i would also go as far to
say
social media anonymity on social media
where where members of parliament
are subject to some of the most
cruel comments attacks
um and they are relentless many of them
are relentless i my colleagues go
through just some of the most appalling
attacks i've seen online and i have as
well but trevor you've asked
specifically about the house of commons
i think first of all parliament in the
house of commons has always been
the home for robust debate and that's
how we articulate robust debate views
etc etc you've asked about the
coarsening of discourse in parliament i
would i i personally and i can only
speak from a personal perspective
i always strive to
ensure that i respect colleagues even
when i disagree a political point or
point of policy that maybe you know
leveled against myself
but
there are some clear guidance as well
the speaker speaks speaks very strongly
about debate tone how we articulate
ourselves present ourselves in
parliament and i know that every
colleague strives to stick with that and
you know conduct themselves in a in a
decent way and it's decency that matters
and respect matters you refer to social
media just
one word one yes or no would you
consider
uh legislation to remove the right to
anonymity on social media well i i want
us to look at everything and there is
work taking place already we've got a
online harms build that will come to
parliament there's work taking place on
it right now
i've done a lot of work on these social
media platforms mainly around encryption
and areas of that nature
but we can't carry on like this i i
spend too much time
actually with communities who have been
under attack basically um who've had all
sorts of postings put online and it's a
struggle to get those postings taken
down we want to we want to make some big
changes on that
home secretary thank you very much
indeed thank you
labour's shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy joins me now from salford
listen andy good morning um
same question i asked the home secretary
what will your memories of david amos be
well i first met david when i was a
newly elected mp just over a decade ago
in fact i think he was one of the first
people that i met
in parliament and it was a fairly
awkward
moment because i've been asked if i
would stand to be an officer of an
all-party parliamentary group that was
looking at children in care and i'd gone
along to this meeting to put my name
forward only to discover that david was
currently the office holder of that post
and hadn't
resigned or stood down or indicated that
he wanted to do so so we have this
little awkward moment where he said well
that's my job and i said oh i thought it
was
my job and he um he anyway he responded
with typical good grace and good nature
i think in the end we shared the
position
and worked together on upholding the
rights of children in care and that was
very very david i think the word that's
come up over and over again from
colleagues on all parts of the political
spectrum art he was just such a nice man
and he was he was courteous he was nice
he had a great sense of humor he wanted
to get the job done and he was willing
to work with whoever it took in order to
do that with great manners great sense
of fun great energy as well and he will
be really really missed by all of us
do you think i've just been talking to
him secretary about this do you think
that there is a danger now that the link
between the member of parliament and the
constituency
will be placed in danger by these events
because
we now have to think much more i guess
about
the safety of people like yourself
i think my bigger fear is that this just
keeps happening and we keep having this
debate and then nothing very much
changes the speaker of the house commons
lindsey hoyle and john burko before him
have made big efforts to try to step up
support and security for mps but the
truth is that this isn't felt equally
there are some mps who are far more at
risk who face far more abuse there was
an online report by amnesty
international a few years ago for
example that found that diane abbott
received half of all the online abuse
levels at members of parliament so there
are additional measures that are needed
not just about security but just about
support for people to be able to go
about their daily lives about proper
advice there's a huge disparity between
the advice and support that's offered by
different police services around the
country i mean i had an experience of
being
accosted outside parliament a few years
ago during a rally um that it was about
um
it was a leave rally around brexit there
was a effigies of sadiq khan and theresa
may being dragged through the street we
were told by police officers we had to
walk through that rally in order to get
into parliament we were surrounded
and there was very little response and
when i complained to the parliamentary
authorities about it and said there were
people standing there watching this
unfold i was told well unfortunately
people have strong views about brexit
and they're entitled to
to um to to to voice them of course i
accept they are but i don't accept that
members of parliament should be blocked
from entering parliament or intimidated
in the course of their daily duties i've
spoken to other members of parliament
who've had an amazing response from
local police forces so it's still very
patchy and i think we've got to get away
from this idea that it's about whether
you protect mps or whether you protect
democracy you have to protect mps to be
able to go about their daily business
and be free to speak on behalf of their
constituents if you want to protect
their democracy we've got to get the
balance right
practically um realistically
i don't think i
managed to get anything very specific
from the home secretary um but
what would you do what um what would you
want to
happen now
that would make
you feel that you could carry out your
democratic duties
in full confidence that you would be
safe
i'm not sure that we could ever get to
that point if i'm honest we've had
stephen timms one of my colleagues was
stabbed a few years ago we had the case
of the lib dem mp before that whose case
worker was killed we've had a plot to
murder rosie cooper my neighbouring mp
and of course what happened to joe and
now david i'm not sure
that that moment is recoverable and i
say that with sadness but i think
there's an element of realism about this
mps are well known in our constituencies
people tend to know where we live we're
out and about we're normal human beings
we go out and about on the weekends and
you know go to the local shops
i'm not sure that we can ever eliminate
the risk but i think there are other
things that can be done to reduce the
risk i think the suggestion from the
speaker about ensuring that anyone who
wants or needs security at surgeries is
a good idea not least because people
often know even if we don't advertise
them that they're happening and so they
can become a magnet for people who want
to cause trouble and i think there's
more that we can do about the political
culture you alluded to it in the
interview with pretty patel but i think
we really do all of us in parliament
need to tone down the rhetoric towards
one another especially when that strays
into rhetoric that is dehumanizing that
treats people not as other fellow human
beings or somehow questions people's
motives most people go into parliament
as you've seen with the outpouring of
love for david most people go into
parliament because they want to make
things better we might disagree on how
to do that but we've got to create a
better culture if we want to actually
achieve it
where we see quite a lot of
what you've just been talking about is
on social media and the home secretary
seemed to
hold open the possibility
that the
right to anonymity which currently
exists on social media
may not be sacrosanct would you support
the idea
that anonymity uh
be is removed from people who post on
social media platforms
i think the difficulty with removing
anonymity altogether is that you've got
pro-democracy protesters and campaigners
you've got
whistleblowers people around the world
who sometimes have to use some level of
anonymity in order to make themselves
heard
and so the debate that we've been having
in parliament through the online safety
bill is about how you get that balance
right there are limits perhaps that you
can put on anonymous accounts for what
they're able to
do and how they're able to interact with
other people
online and that have to be surely there
has to be repercussions for people
engaging in what would be criminal
behavior if it happened in person but
doing so online whether they're
anonymous
or otherwise i have to say i listen to
pretty patel talking about online safety
and you know i know that she gets a lot
of abuse on social media as well and i'm
extremely sympathetic but it is a bit
rich for the home secretary to say that
she takes that very seriously when the
government have been dragging their feet
on this legislation for years
and currently we're at a situation where
they're not proposing that there'll be
any penalties for top executives of tech
companies who don't abide by the online
proposed code if there are repeated
breaches of that code if they're not
upholding their responsibilities there
ought to be penalties for that we can't
continue with a situation in which diane
abbott once described as the wild west
where some people are targeted so
severely that it does impact on their
ability to speak out not just mps but
you know young people particularly voice
those concerns as well many of them
driven offline by the amount of hate
that is on there
so on social media you would be open to
some limits on anonymity and also
new penalties for the social media
platforms
yes and we've got to you know as i say
we've got to get the balance right
because social media can be an enormous
force for good i see it very much in the
course of my day job where you've got
some incredible
campaigners the women of belarus the
pro-democracy protesters in hong kong
the young people of afghanistan they've
managed to use social media in order to
make themselves heard and if you speak
to childline they'll say that social
media has been a major problem for a lot
of young people but it's also been a way
in which young people can now reach out
and get help in a way that they couldn't
when i was a child so we've got to get
the balance right to make sure that we
use this as a force for good in every
era where we've been through
technological revolutions that's always
been the case the one thing i do agree
with pretty patel about is that i really
don't think that we've got to grips with
this yet we haven't worked out how to
manage it so that it works in the
interest of democracy rather than
working against it
lisa nandy thank you very much indeed
now the link between constituency and mp
is obviously in sharp focus this weekend
not every former prime minister enjoyed
staying on the back benches after their
time in number 10 but gordon brown did
and he was there for a further five
years as mp for kakadi and cowden beef
he joins me now from
fife
good morning
gordon brown do you
have a memory of uh david amos
yes my first thoughts of course are with
his widow julia and their five children
this is a terrible tragedy i remember
david entered the same same time as me
to the house of commons i think he was
the person i remember most because
almost every question and every speech
he made he always mentioned the name of
his constituency and that shows just how
much he was in touch with his local
community
hard-working determined caring
compassionate we've heard all this that
emphasizes just what a good man of the
people he actually was and this is
beyond partisanship
you've got to pay respects to someone
who really
died doing something that he enjoyed
most which was listening to
consulting
helping
serving his constituents and i i will
remember him as a as a great
constituency mp as i know everybody else
will who is in the house of commons
today
also
what of course has emerged in the
discussion of the aftermath of this
dreadful event
is the
relationship between
the member of parliament and the
constituency
is there a danger that we now find
ourselves willingly
having the culture of our democracy in
some way eroded because of because
public figures have to retreat behind a
wall of security of some kind
yet trevor trevor this is an attack on
our democracy
so the answer cannot be less democracy
this looks as if it is a terrorist
incident
it is probably related to al-shabaab or
to al-qaeda and we'll find out more in
the next few days
but the answer when you come across a
terrorist incident
is we don't blink we don't shirk we
don't flinch we don't show weakness
we stand up for what we believe and of
course we will increase the security
that is available to members of
parliament and councillors when they're
doing their surgeries and that is
something that must happen immediately
but it's true also to say that we must
not allow our democracy to be diminished
because a terrorist attack has occurred
i think the history of dealing with
terrorism is that if you ever show
weakness and you ever give the
impression that coexistence is
impossible and that you're going to back
away
and give up on your values
then you show something that gives
terrorist hope and we must not do that
you know hearts are broken but our
resolve must be unbreakable
a life has been tragically destroyed but
our values are democratic values they
are indestructible and we must show that
now
if you were in government now would you
consider for example you as a former
prime minister i think is are entitled
to close protection i bodyguards and so
on
would you
favor
making that possibility available to
members of parliament now
yes because if there is a risk to
anybody who is a member of the general
public or a member of parliament
and the risk is apparent to the police
authorities
they will do everything in their power
to protect that person and i think what
the speaker is doing and harriet
harmon's called for a speaker's
conference on this
is absolutely right we must say to
members of parliament of course be
careful where you hold your constituency
surgeries in a place that is protected
but at the same time if you need police
protection uh that is going to be
available
and it need not be obtrusive it need not
be so obvious but i think the protection
has got to be made available now to
members of parliament who feel that
there is a risk to what they are doing
uh and i think that will be introduced
in the next few days
one of the things that i imagine that uh
david amerson we both knew him well
would probably be saying
though
he's a man of great compassion kindness
and if this had happened to somebody
else he would be the first to express
his sorrow but he i guess he would also
be saying
that
events should not come in
the way of uh public servants
continuing to do
what the important things they need to
do looking after their constituents and
i want to talk to you about one of the
human issues that you've raised which is
of course
the impact of covet particularly in
developing countries um
when we last spoke which is back in june
you
said that there were millions of doses
of
vaccines which you thought should be
shipped to developing countries we're
sitting in storehouses in europe
where are we on that now
but you're right to ask this question
because
we've got a detailed report appearing
tomorrow
that shows there are 240 million
vaccines
that are lying in europe and america
that are unused not likely to be used
for months many of them may go to waste
and that would be criminal which could
immediately be airlifted out to those
countries where the level of vaccination
is so low
that not even the nurses and doctors are
protected and certainly not the elderly
vulnerable
and you know boris johnson promised at
the g7
that he was going to vaccinate the whole
world he made this bold announcement
that by next year everybody would be
vaccinated who was an adult in the
developing world as well as the
developed world
but since then so little has happened
that we now face the possibility that
every target is being missed 10 percent
by september missed 40 by december
likely to be missed 70 percent by next
year likely to be missed and so we've
got to take action immediately
to use these unused vaccines
to save lives you know 100 000 lives
have been saved in britain because of a
hundred million vaccines how many more
lives can be saved in the rest of the
world if we get these vaccines to people
who need them
you um
if i may
say so you used the word criminal there
in an answer which you also refer to the
prime minister um
why do you think this hasn't happened
is it just incompetence or is there
something deeper going on here
i i i was talking about neglect
and i do think that this is a lack of
coordination
if president biden boris johnson or sula
van at the european union
justin trudeau if they came together
they would find that they had these
unused vaccines
that they're not going to use them even
after all the boosters they are excess
vaccines that are not going to be used
and they should get them out as quickly
as possible
and month by month this number of ex
extra vaccines will grow
another 200 million next month 200
million by the end of the year a billion
in total by january now we've got to get
them to the people who need them
otherwise
people will say
that the neglect is unacceptable if 100
million or so vaccines as we predict go
to waste because they pass the use by
date this is the biggest public policy
failure at an international level for
years
outside their war in peace time and
really to save hundreds of thousands of
lives by using the vaccine the miracle
of which is available to us
is something that needs the coordination
of the leaders only they can release the
vaccines not the imf or the world health
organization the leaders have got to
make that decision they ordered the
vaccines they over ordered and they can
now make them available
if i recall correctly when we discussed
it before actually on the
very day
i think that the president of the united
states was calling a meeting
of uh his fellow g7 leaders to do
exactly what you've just said
why didn't that
happen i mean why didn't we hear more
about that
well i think it was a tragedy that the
meeting
went round the table i don't think boris
johnson was there from the information
that i have although he was down to
speak as right at the beginning of the
event it went round the table people
made promises but they didn't add up to
being enough to get the vaccinations to
people at the time that they needed them
and so we have promises about next year
and we have some vaccines going this
year but we'll never meet the 40 target
unless we take action now and that's an
airlift it needs an airlift now
boris did you say that boris johnson
wasn't in the room when they were
talking about this
well downing street has refused to
confirm that he was there
and yet he made the promise that he was
going to get the world vaccinated and
the big summit that was to be held and
was held under the office of president
biden if as people are saying he did not
attend and i think he's better answer to
the house of commons about why a promise
was made at the g7 that he was going to
oversee and then when it came to the
meetings that had to deal with at a
vaccine summit including the secretary
general of the united nations president
of the european union uh the prime
minister of canada everybody else was
there prime minister draghi of italy
we have to ask what role did he play in
that summit
can i just uh briefly return to the uh
issue of this morning
and ask you about the tone of politics
right now
i spoke both to the home secretary and
to lisa nandy about this and both of
them
i think seem to
uh
confirm what a lot of people are saying
that
without wanting to trace this particular
event to
uh you know the wider political
discourse that there is some
an edge an unpleasantness a coarseness
that's entered
uh political speech and debate
which uh
from their point of view we could well
do without what is your view
yeah i think you can disagree without
being disagreeable and i think
you can have discord without having
malice
and too often i think political
arguments descend
into personal
attacks and personal
uh conflicts
and i think when it comes to the social
media we've got to look again at the way
these algorithms are organized
because they push people towards the
most extreme positions
and and the media looks to me like a
shouting match without an umpire but the
most extreme positions are the ones that
come across
now this is i think partly because of
the way that um the different media
organizations organize their information
and i think something's got to be done
to look at
online harm that is resulting from this
so yes we've got to clean up here but
let us also remember that if this is a
terrorist incident we are dealing with a
group of terrorists or a group
around a terrorist
who believe that coexistence with the
west is impossible
and we have got to show by the strength
of our democracy and the strength by
which we reach out to other countries
and call for cooperation that this is
not the way that we see the world and
this is not the way the world has got to
be
terrorism has got to be fought directly
head on
gordon brown thank you very much indeed
thank you
tributes to sir david amos have come in
from across the political divide with
many pointing to his commitment to the
local area and his constituents i want
to speak now to two members of
parliament from the essex region the
conservative mp for romford andrew
rossendell who's been friends with david
for 40 years and the labour mp for
ilford north west streeting um
thank you gentlemen for joining us it's
unusual for us to have
two members of parliament on together
especially from different
parties but i'd like you both to reflect
on your
experience not as partisans but as
constituency mps who who
were
close to david um
and i just would like starting with you
andrew uh
if you want to say something about your
memories of him
david was a wonderful person he was a
really genuine friend
we've all got friends in parliament he
was special because he really cared
about
the people around him he cared about his
constituency
he was a passionate person and he had
strong beliefs he he was uncompromising
what he stood for
but the things he stood for
were wonderful causes for instance
animal welfare he was
he was a huge animal welfare supporter
and
the other thing i'd say about him is
that
he would
always have time for everybody he met
you know he didn't just brush you off he
he would spend time talking to all all
the people he met
and nothing would be too much he never
looked down on anyone he was he he was
an equal to everyone else that's the way
he
he behaved and
we're going to miss him he was a
fantastic mp and a great friend and
for him to lose him in this such tragic
circumstances
is very difficult for us to accept and
understand it really is it's a very sad
moment for all of us
we're streaming
yeah i think we were just discussing
before we came on um david was one of
those great characters in parliament
everyone knew him because you could not
know him he was
renowned for as andrew said the cause he
took up
a terrific sense of humor and also
just the most outstanding champion for
his constituency and i've not checked
but i would put money on the fact that
no one has ever mentioned south end in
parliament more than sir david did and
i'm really glad actually that the
campaign for city status for south end
is um you know really up at the top of
the agenda because i could think of no
more fitting tribute to him and he was
loved right across the political
spectrum and you've heard that in recent
days from some of my labor colleagues
who absolutely love david loved working
for him and i don't think that
there's any real comfort that we could
offer his family today but i hope they
draw some small comfort from just how
much
you know a husband a father was just
loved right across the political
spectrum in the house of commons and
evidently loved by his constituents as
we've seen in the outpouring of grief
and love for david in the last day or so
the conversation this morning has
centered very much on the security
of members of parliament and
i would guess also local councillors who
have to meet people they don't know face
to face um and there's some suggestion
that actually over recent times
things have become
more dangerous uh certainly rougher
has either of you
have you had to take uh extra
precautions over your period uh as
members of parliament andrew rossendale
first
um yes i'm afraid i've been mp 20 years
and during that period
uh i see
a lot of more nasty people around than
ever before and they're willing to say
and do things
in a way that i would never thought
possible in this country and we all have
to be really aware and keep our wits
about us the abuse we get on social
media by emails i mean we get it all the
time but we brush it off because we've
got a job to do and
we tell the police the police have got
other things to do it's not always
followed up
and i think probably this is all going
to change we've got to take this a bit
more seriously in future i've had my
office was arsoned my car was smashed up
someone tried to get into my house and
injure me managed to stop them all these
things have happened over the years but
you take it in your stride because
our priority is to to get on with our
job and we we we do tend to not think
much about our own security i'm afraid
but i'm thinking now maybe we should do
a bit more um
pretty patel's reviewing
how we're going to be how this is going
to be dealt with in future certainly our
constituency surgeries there's going to
be have to be some new arrangements for
those but we can't let evil destroy
democracy and this was pure evil what
happened here we cannot allow that to
undermine the democratic traditions of
this country so whatever happens
where's myself and all members of
parliament we're going to be out there
serving our constituents we're not going
to let this defeat us we'll still be
there and doing the job we're elected to
do
we're streeting andrew rosendale says we
have to do a bit more
what in your view would a bit more in
practical terms constitute
uh i think it's a good question trevor
and i don't know what the answer is to
be honest um
i think
the thing about the accessibility of
politicians in britain and it's when
i've met politicians from other
countries they they remark upon it it's
not just that we do it because we feel
obliged to and we think it's part of the
job we do it because we love doing it we
love spending time in our communities we
love spending time with our constituents
and we you know we're people people we
like spending time with people that's
why we're in politics to make a
difference and to serve people so so i
think
none of us really want to change that we
don't want to take measures that that
undermine that but we're having
difficult conversations with our own
families this is not just about us it's
about the safety of our staff the people
who work for us it's about you know how
our families feel when we go off to work
and the conversation that particularly
you know our colleagues who are parents
have been having with their children in
the last day or so about why our job's
important and why it's worth the risk
but you know this is the second
second
incident like this in five years and you
know we've been stricken with grief for
david grief for joe
and you know and also grief for the job
that we do in a sense because
you know
we love it we love what we do david was
the epitome of loving public service
um so we know that something's got to
change but it you know i think
it's so raw and we don't want to kind of
rush to kind of
snap judgments but we know something's
got to change
there's a lot of talk about reviews and
consideration and so on but
are we going to be here again in
three years four years five years
uh as frankly we were on to
the joe cox murder where everybody said
we have things have to change
but actually
it's hard to
identify a practical
measure that has been taken
where's
i i i really hope not um
you know the truth is that we
we are exposed every day to risk but
i want to take it serious but i also
think that there are lots of people who
are exposed to risk every day who serve
the public
we're not unique in that sense and we're
not special case um
and i don't want people watching your
program this morning who would be
outstanding public servants whether as
counselors or members of parliament or
working in other public facing roles to
think this is no longer for me i don't
want to do that i i can't tell you
trevor how much i love doing this job um
and i know i speak for andrew on this
because you know
lived in your constituency at one point
parliamentary neighbors even though
andrew drives around my constituency
every election with his loudhailer
trying to get me out you know i can sit
around you a cross-party friend um we
love doing this job absolutely love it
and i wouldn't want anyone to be put off
but part of that has got to be i'm sure
making sure we're safe
andrew rosendale um
many people would say that
part of what we are seeing now
is an atmosphere that is generated by
a heightened
rhetoric
and the way that people talk about talk
about and to each other in politics at
not least members of parliament
themselves
to what extent
do you think that this changed
atmosphere actually
is the responsibility of
parliamentarians themselves call you
know people who call others enemies of
the people people who call other people
scum for example
so
we're all in politics
and we accept that we are going to be
criticized for our views not everyone
agrees with our opinions and i don't
mind a political debate i don't mind
people attacking me because they
disagree with my views on whatever
subject it may be however there is a
level to which that's it is acceptable
to have that kind of debate if you use
nasty hateful language if you if you use
language which is going to
place you in a position whereby you look
like you
you hate that person because their views
that's not acceptable and there are
some politicians who have said things
they shouldn't have said
um i don't think that's been the cause
of this though it may be part of the
background to i don't know we'll find
out in due course but we we all have a
responsibility to show respect for each
other to show kindness um despite our
political differences and wesley are
probably example of that you know we're
neighboring seats we've never had a bad
word to say about each other that quite
the opposite
but we have different views on issues um
we always will because we're different
parties but it doesn't stop us being
friends and colleagues it doesn't stop
us working together on issues and we
agree on far more than the public think
actually
it's amazing how many mps on other side
of the house that i agree with on issues
and it's not all it's not all
bad feeling between us and sometimes the
media can project it like we're all at
each other but we're not
there's a lot of things that we agree on
and work together on
uh but we've got to be careful of our
language and we've all got to make sure
that when we speak in public and when we
tweet things out and when we issue
statements that that we show respect for
other people even if they're
diametrically opposed to our particular
point of view
we're streeting um
i
remember
after uh
joe cox died
much of the language that we're hearing
this weekend of kindness and
more in common than we that separates us
and so on being used and people
promising that they would be more
respectful and so on um
i think it took roughly six weeks for
members of parliament to be yelling at
each other across the
aisle again
now
you know you two
are not known particularly for that kind
of thing
what can we actually do
to make sure that all of the good
intentions that are going to be
expressed today and tomorrow and the day
after
last into next year
well it takes it takes work and it takes
some effort and
you know i think you're a bit too
generous there i can i think if you ask
the speaker or successive speakers i've
got quite a loud voice in the commons
chamber and the irony is as much as
people say they don't like the the the
jeering and the yelling at prime
minister's questions it's the most
watched part of the week um
i i think that
the the the the rough and tumble of
politics the you know the the rgb of
debate that's part of it i think there
are times when you know intemperate
language can go too far and i wish that
it wouldn't take awful tragedies like
this for us to
remind ourselves and and particularly to
remind the public that we do actually
quite like each other actually across
the political spectrum there are lots of
cross-party friendships and as i say
whenever i do a school visit in my
constituency when i look across the
commons chamber to conservative mps i
don't see a bunch of people who are evil
i see people who like me are motivated
by a commitment to public service and
wanting to make our country a better
place we just differ on how to do that
and that's what politics is all about um
and and i think we can make that point
more often without losing robust debate
i think robust debate is a healthy part
of democracy
but i think i think perhaps we might
impugn each other's motives a little
less um
and also i mean i think we've also got
to
it's always the time to talk about
civility and politics i think we've also
got to reflect on the specific
circumstances of as to how two members
of parliament have lost their lives in
this way and i think that's about more
than civility it's about extremism we've
got to tackle that too
right we're streeting andrew rosendale
thank you very much indeed for joining
us
thank you
now so david was well known for a number
of causes close to his heart
not least the treatment of animals for
which he was famous and he was also a
spirited campaigner supporter of many
other charities
he is speaking at the royal albert hall
a couple of years back at a concert
organized by the music man project uh
where by the way i myself was present a
charity he passionately supported as
patron
it's been enjoyed by you
the family and friends and relatives
and i can only just begin to imagine
how each and every one of you
must be bursting with pride at what
these people have achieved
[Applause]
tonight i can now speak to the founder
and chief executive of that charity
david stanley who
lives in lyon c um
david uh
the thing that struck me most on
that day that that concert was that
david amos seemed to know everybody in
the place and this is royal albert hall
absolutely trevor um
there we were at the albert hall 3 000
people and hundreds performing the vast
majority
musicians from the music man project and
yet sir david amos
was in his element waving speaking to
everybody knew sir david
and
on that night he was just beaming with
pride
because
the dream of having
a huge capacity audience watching
musicians with learning disabilities
inspire
that audience that iconic venue
had come true and largely that was
thanks to the help from sir david
can you tell us a bit about
how he worked with you his involvement
in the charity
yes well i mean i've known sir david for
over 25 years initially just as a
musician in in his constituency
and then after a while he he lent his
support to my work and he would always
ask me
david what can i do to help what can i
do to help you fulfill your dreams
how can i help your charity
all the time that's what he would say
and
for me that was to
open doors you see
i'm a musician and a teacher
but sir david amos
had the access the the influence
to campaign for my charities for greater
opportunities and you must remember that
only a few decades ago people with
learning disabilities would have been
hidden away
there's no
real chance for them to change their
destiny and to create opportunities like
that and
we went on this journey together and he
opened doors that i couldn't open he
he campaigned he fundraised he he just
told everybody and he we had this
wonderful
way of coming up with grand ideas and
grand plans uh the london palladium
breaking a world record performing to
members of the royal family and
ultimately the albert hall and
you know we were then going to go on and
try and get a concert tour to broadway
he was such an exciting
man to know because i always felt that
everything was possible with sir david
and
he was just so proud of south end
you are in leoncy which is uh just a
little bit outside of south and um in
fact i lived in leoncy for a little
while when i worked at an
oil refinery along the estuary it's a
very quiet place it's a dormitory town
um it's possibly the last place you
would have
imagined something like this happening
what impact do you think it's going to
have on leon c
well i mean it's just a devastating
shock
but i think
as the days and the weeks and the months
go by
i i do feel as if the the town
and particularly the leon c part of
south end will
sadly have changed
it is on on all of us to try and make
sure that we continue that positive
legacy of sir david
but you're right this is a peaceful
town a peaceful part of
of south end and
it's just so tragic
that
someone so great
someone that
has done so much for his people
well in a sense we're now going to be
remembered
for such a tragedy
and
i think that is probably one of the most
awful aspects of this
david um
you're right we probably don't want to
remember
him
for what happened on friday though to
some extent that's going to be
unavoidable but if you
were to
if you like
pen
the legacy of sir david amos as somebody
who's known him a long time who lived
locally in his constituency
what would you want it to be
well so much but i think probably
a champion of people
the champion of south end
but most of all an outstanding
constituency mp
that seemed to me
to be happier serving his people
helping his people than anything else in
his life
and
the legacy must be
city status if we can
the legacy
must be the continuation of his work for
his charities
but most of all
i want to remember him for the person
who
stood up for the people
that were vulnerable
that were difficult to reach
that were the people that often were
left behind
and that is perhaps what people don't
know so much about sir david amos
david stanley thank you very much indeed
thank you well that is it from us this
morning it has been
a somber show and if i
may just say
uh a sad one for me this is somebody i
knew
from
before he was elected
battled an mp in 1983 as a young
reporter and him as a young politician a
remarkable man
someone we should always remember
see you next week
[Music]
you